alors les chéris il était une fois tpp
et oui 1er avril vous rappeler de ce 1er
avril
alors je vous racontais on avait démarré
sur france 4 c'est vrai que au départ
j'avais fait un grand casting de
chroniqueurs j'avais été voir france
télévisions france télévisions je
faisais fa si la chanter à l'époque et
je savais que fa si la chanter ça
n'allait pas durer très longtemps donc
je vais aller voir bruno gaston qui
était le directeur d'épreuve de l'époque
et nicolas pernikoff qu'on a on a la
chance qui travaillent avec nous
maintenant j'ai et je leur ai dit voilà
je voudrais faire une émission sur les
médias
voilà donc qui regardent la télé c'est à
dire la télé qui regardent la télé et on
ferait une émission voilà on donnerait
notre avis comme ça avec des
spécialistes et les alors on a démarré
sur france 4 me rappelle la première
audience on avait fait 190 mille
téléspectateurs et david jaoui qui était
le directeur d'antenne qu'il restait
toujours un ami m'avait appelé ma vie
dit c'est pas mal pour une première voie
là mais il faut voir ensuite on avait
joué le dis on avait baissé 120000
115000 et puis y'a comme il ya eu un
petit à petit un petit voilà je vous dis
un petit buzz sur les réseaux sociaux
sur facebook où les gens commençaient à
dire il ya une émission où il ya une
bande de tarés qui disent des conneries
c'est le jeudi soir sur france 4
à 22h40 alors c'est vrai que voilà on a
commencé à a pas parlé nous c'est vrai
que moi je m'en rappelle j'avais fait un
dossier
je me rappelle à l'imprimante avec mon
ami yannick voilà qu'hier mais mes
meilleures amies on avait sorti le
dossier on avait été à france 4 avec
notre petit dossier on avait vraiment
bien préparé les choses avec des
chroniques des rubriques et puis ça a
commencé à peser un peu sur les réseaux
sociaux sur facebook un moment on avait
plus de gens qui étaient abonnées à
l'émission sur facebook que de gens qui
nous regardent et donc conseillé
peut-être qu'il se passe un truc
et voilà ça commençait à monter deux
cent mille trois cent mille jusqu'au
jour où c'est vrai qu'un jour en
deuxième partie de soirée on avait fait
cinq cent quarante mille téléspectateurs
je me rappelle c'est guy lagache
l'invité qui était sur m6 à l'époque
pour capitale et dans on s'est dit il se
passe quelque chose et on avait fait une
deuxième année on est dos sur france 4
et l'émission a commencé à monter en
puissance
voilà et c'est vrai qu'au départ il y
avait vingt trente personnes au public
alors ça les fait plaisir de voir
valérie qui est magnifique regarder la
baloche qu'on n'a pas vue depuis
longtemps ma chérie qui est là tu es
magnifique chéri mais merci d'être là
avec nous mais c'est un plaisir qui
pense pas à aucun moment je pouvait
louper les dix ans pmtc une partie mais
pour sûr bien la fonctionnelle vous
présente tout le monde ce soir je crois
qu'on a eric mendez aussi ça lui montrer
comment ça va mon chéri bien mais cyril
c'est reçu plein du toit
alors éric sa fidèle à il fait partie de
la bande voilà je vous le dis pour moi
comme dit benhaim il ya le cinquième
chroniqueurs on se tait sur son émission
lui c'est le onzième chroniqueur c'est
lui qui s'occupe du planisme voilà irish
qui qui prépare le public juste avant
voilà et qui leur dit voilà on va
arriver on va rigoler on va s'amuser et
l'ict avec moi depuis france 4 et tu
sais que tu es un monde a tué mon ami tu
sais que voilà tu étais le meilleur
aujourd'hui 2 comptant quelque chose à
dire franchement si j'avais
antichrétiens merci merci de ta fidélité
franchement tu es un mec exceptionnel
seul team et nous avons tout le monde va
croire que je l'assumé vraiment 7 et 10
ans au max en sambre dix ans et n'a pas
changé parfois ce sont des messages mais
eux et tu réponds direct vraiment le
même franchement reste comme des est
franchement très vaste à serge russo que
c'est vrai j'ai posé avec pas mal de
l'animateur toi tu bosses avec pas mal d
animateurs et je peux vous dire que
cyril et les gens venaient en plateau
vous verrez le mec c'est un des seuls
animateurs qui reste dix minutes à la
fin de l'émission un public qui fait ça
tient surtout parce que j'ai rien à
[ __ ] le mec reste figée pas d'année
alors ta démission
c'est vrai mais les dragons de sécurité
qui sont bien les faucons au liban
[Musique]
franchement mec t'es un mec super
comme j'avais dessiné en début
d'émission ce soit de vous montrer aussi
ceux qui sont voilà derrière un bien
entendu tous ceux qui sont derrière tous
ceux qui travaillent dans l'ombre et il
ya notamment mon fabien de lettre fabien
de l'être alors c'est la première
personne que j'ai recruté
lorsque j'ai monté ma boîte de
production c'est vrai c'était avec mon
ami stéphane gâteau et et jérôme revon
voilà il était avec moi dans le bureau
on était tous les deux et c'est vrai que
on n'avait rien à faire de la journée
on sait ni un moment il ya bien
quelqu'un qui va nous appeler fabien de
l'été la voilà ces banques les ont
emmené le lien qu il est venu me voir à
la sortie de la radio 1 ils étaient à la
sortie de la radio il est venue de
guingamp il est venu me voir à la sortie
de rire et chansons trapel mot chez nous
pas à l'étagé colaprete à l'époque ce
que vous voyez tunisienne dessus vous
savez comment ça va connard tu avais
demandé s'il y avait du travail tu
m'avais dit oui beaucoup
il y avait rien à faire
est ce que tu te souviens cyril au tout
début quand on est bon on était que tous
les deux et une eu envie de décrocher
toujours avant toi pour faire ce genre
de 20 étages
oui civile mais je me rappelle
on était dans un bureau je raconte aux
téléspectateurs n'étaient dans un bureau
de 10 mètres carrés et georges mettez
deux heures pour prendre le téléphone
genre il m'appelait de très loin jean
radio bat fabien delhaye qui travaillent
avec moi maintenant depuis des années
c'est mon frère voilà je le dis merci
mot fabien et l'année prochaine on va
beaucoup faire plus de happening donc tu
vas ans tu vas être avec moi et et je
rêve je vous le dis depuis des années de
le mettre à l'antenne avec nous autour
de la table de tpm pays voilà il veut
pas voilà je le dis voilà je dis aux
téléspectateurs cela fait des années que
je lui dis tu dois être avec moi tu dois
être avec moi et il veut pas j'espère
qu'un jour il changera d'avis il ya le
président qui nous a rejoint regardez
comme il est beau regarder comme il est
chic notre présidente s'est vite c'est
vrai que franck appelé tôt dès que je
suis arrivé sur ces 8 il était déjà là
bas on se connaissait un petit peu avec
franck happi dos parce qu'il travaillait
sur comédie avant s'étaient rencontrés
voilà on avait mangé une pizza ensemble
et tout de suite ça avait collé et mon
franck maintenant c'est devenu mon frère
vraiment mon bonbon vraiment mais quand
je dis mon frère c'est pas comme s'ils
allaient le civil nom cyrill comme je ne
sais pas c'est pas une expression c'est
vrai mon chéri ouais je voulais leur
père s'est joué voilà pour les dix ans
mon chéri tu es notre président bien
évidemment là comme ça on en aura on
n'aura plus jamais un mot chéri est ce
que c'est que ces heureux de nous voir
parce que c'est super je suis super
super émue de vous voir je suis là je
comprends par valérie gilles mathieu
évidemment et benjamin évidemment je
suis évidemment présent à tes côtés mon
frérot je peine d'amour tu es un génie
de la télé je pense que tous les gens
qui vont témoigner ce soir savent à quel
point on s'amuse depuis alors moi depuis
à 8 ans même si on s'est connus au
démarrage de sur france 4 mai mais quel
plaisir de travailler avec toi quelle
folie qu'elle
quelles libertés quelle bonheur c'est
vraiment une grande joie et c'est pour
nous une aventure télévisuelle
absolument unis pour le sait tous et eon
qui ça et c'est en grande partie grâce à
toi
vraiment c'est la non mais tu sais on
est dans une période de confinement le
puits soit avec nous tous les soirs
c'est un peu notre raison d'être en ce
moment les gens témoigne le témoignage à
longueur de journée de l'affection et
l'amour à deux portes et moi je te
connais je sais qui tu es tu es un homme
de grand coeur
voilà il ya ya ya ya plein de choses que
tu fais sans les caméras qui font des
choses absolument merveilleuse vallée
rite un truc à dire voilà parce que pour
la liberté bidoit ça fait huit ans qu'on
est sûr c'est vite et c'est vrai qu'on a
connu et on va connaître encore j'espère
plein d'émotions c'est vrai que c'est
incroyable oui oui non ce qui est
surtout est-ce que ce que disaient mes
petits camarades par rapport à franck
c'est l'humanité de ce rang qu'ils ne
considèrent pas simplement comme des
machines à animer mais comme des êtres
humains
et ça c'est dans une relation
professionnelle c'est assez incroyable
d'avoir ça il sait s'adapter à la
personnalité de chacun avec énormément
bienveillance d'écouté en même temps il
sait très bien ce qu'il a envie ce dont
il a envie ils marchent main dans la
main ils savaient exactement vous voulez
qu'on aille zen d'amour vraiment me
manquer a bientôt qu'on a quelqu'un qui
va nous faire une petite surprise
cl voilà qui était aussi au début de tp
mpc et nos raquettes avec nous commence
à 20h irin ça va et d'eau est pourquoi
qu'elle et enora elles ont l'air plus en
forme que les vôtres que ce qu'ils ont
des têtes celle où kelly et n'aura cédé
deux seuls qui sont fraîches sur la tête
de la vie regardez en soient tous des
têtes donc normal mais sans rigoler
c'est bien peu choquerait tu vois c'est
quand même les dix ans en fait ça va mon
hainaut ouais ça va écoute moi je fais
que bouffer on est sur une prise de
kilos en une le quotidien les fais toi
plaisir et fera le bilan
on fera le bilan après le confinement on
s'en fout enoh qui fait toujours partie
de la famille je devrais lire pascal
avec eric dans de quoi j'me mêle et
c'est la famille un eric naulleau bien
entendu je voudrais dire est ce que toi
tu as un souvenir de tpm puis j'en ai
plein j'en ai plein moi je dois en
partage et deux avec toi un collectif et
un perso le collectif rapidement ses
quais se cache cache géant
on avait fait un tabac organisé gad
elmaleh qui tout bien mais comme alors
je me suis dit mais quelle émission de
télé alors que normalement un
cache-cache c'est un truc entre soit tu
vois voilà quelle émission capable de
défoncer un coup de cutter et
d'organiser
cache-cache avec tous les copains je me
souviens de jean-mi étiquetté en premier
degré on se cachait vraiment donc c'est
et où est sa tinfos des souvenirs où je
sais que tout le monde n'en a parlé
après pendant des années tellement c'est
un moment de télé le deuxième
personnellement c'est que grâce à toi
j'ai quand même sauté dans le vide en un
saut à l'élastique de malades et ça et
ça je suis désolé encore une fois que
l'émission de télé le permet avec toutes
les conditions de sécurité évidemment
autour et avec les copains derrière qui
m'encourageait toi qui étais une
personne est pas bon tu as fait des
trucs de aux fins d'enquêté mais comme
nous tous on a fait des trucs que
normalement les gens de fonctions me
sont très bons et dont je fais de gros
bisous matière merci d'avoir été là et
vous eh bien je voir vite matière et on
t'embrasse fort
il nous a rejoints il faisait partie de
la toute première bande de tpm p même la
toute première émission sur france 4
c'est le 1er avril 2010
ces mots thierry moreau comme un savant
bon thierry vin très très bien et vous
comment te voir mon chéri % de voix soit
aussi bon elle n'a pas changé il ya bien
eu quelques années mais vous n'avez pas
de changer en tout cas aborder toujours
on est toujours aussi en forme
gilles est toujours aussi floue matière
et d'amour est ce que tu te rappelles de
ta première parce que j'étais première
live pour oui je me rappelle de ma
première parce qu'en fait j'avais
avaient été tués une telle injection qui
s'applique pas fall époque était
diffusée sur paris première
je vais contacter pour un casting quand
je dis aux gens de paris première que
j'allais faire ce casting on dit mais
qu'est ce que tu vas faire avec ceux se
fout de syrie la tna moi je te plaît ne
sont pas les potes je suis parti pour
fair touche pas à mon poste j'ai quitté
mon épaule était sûr uniquement un stade
où je partais sur un truc qui marcherait
jamais ça et puis je pars ça a été deux
mois après et ben et voilà et on fête
les 10 ans aujourd'hui et mon thierry je
suis très heureux que tu sois avec nous
pour les dix ans on tire est ce que tu
peux nous faire une petite blague c'est
une blague pourrie un bien évidemment ça
se passe dans un bar aria
il ya un policier qui rentre dans le
bureau du commissaire et qui dit
chercher il ya un braquage de la
supérette
on a volé 5 kg de carottes et des
cartouches de cigarettes et le
commissaire répond et vous avez un
suspect et
on recherche un lapin qui tousse
pierrick je te fait de grandes maisons
vont tirer les bonnes routes est
vraiment pas ce que tu fais sur lci
bravo mon chéri bonjour à tous c'est
jean pierre foucault bi trans et miss
quercy c'est camille combal
j'en profite pour souhaiter un très bel
anniversaire à l'émission tpm paie bien
sûr merci à cyril merci aux camarades
puis surtout un immense merci aux
téléspectateurs de tpm paix à qui je
dois tant qu'ils me suivent depuis
maintenant pas mal d'années pour
continuer à me suivre
merci beaucoup pour la force vous êtes
adorable vraiment j'espère que tout va
bien pour vous jabra ses équipes
techniques aussi bien sûr que j'ai pas
vu depuis longtemps et qui bosse
énormément qu'on voit pas forcément à
l'antenne bien sûr amusez vous bien et
ça lui